If someone wants to get a malgum fillings removed, do you feel it's really important to have this done by a dentist that specializes in this?
We haven't had the best of luck with a dentist that specializes in this and it was very costly.
So we are considered having a regular dentist who we are very happy would do this. Any suggestions or thoughts?
Yes, I do have thoughts on that.
So if your regular dentist is going to take out...
I am assuming you are saying a mercury fillings. You have the silver mercury fillings.
So if you just have a regular malgum fillings like a white fillings that you are going to have removed because it needs to be replaced, you don't have to worry about that at all.
But if you are getting a mercury fillings removed, silver fillings, you do have to take precautions.
The precautions that should be taken is that you should have a rubber dam and they should be very careful that they are suctioning up any silver that is broken off the tooth as they are replacing it so that you are not swallowing it.
Number two, you should have a mercury vacuum because when they are drilling out the mercury fillings, it is gasifying.
And you are just breathing it right in and you will get it in your system faster that way than if you swallowed it.
If you swallowed the mercury, you have a decent chance if you have a healthy gut, a healthy gut lining that you won't absorb it and you will deposit it into the toilet.
If you breathe it in, it is going to go right across the alveolar space.
So gasified mercury is readily transferred into the blood and that is the biggest hindrance. So they need to have a mercury vacuum.
And then lastly, they should put a nasal cannula over your nose so you are breathing in that nasal cannula and then put a wet wash rag folded up over your nose so you are not breathing in any of that.
So you will obviously be breathing through your mouth when your mouth is open and it is inadvertently you are going to absorb some of that mercury so you do want to be taken a key later which is my favorite is our key la clear to get some phase zero key la clear which has got DMSA EDTA and several other things in there to key light that out.
So if you are a current doctor who you really like will take those measures, they don't have to be listed as a biological dentist.
You just want to make sure they are taking those measures. If it is not a silver filling that you are talking about, then you don't have to worry about any of those things.